bevor das video hier ist da ich im
moment losgehen wollte ich dann ganz
kurz darüber informieren dass soeben
eine neue folge die kontrollen gegangen
ist also eine neue folge des podcast von
sandra und hier ist soeben online
gegangen auf apple broadcast auch
spotify auf dieser wo auch immer ihr
euch das anderen wollte ich haben fragen
beantwortet habe ich müssen erzählen was
gerade los ist in unserem leben also
nimmt das los und in der beschreibung
jetzt geht das mal das video losen
danach könnt ihr euch den podcast
anhören
herzlich willkommen wir heute meine
lieben zuschauer zu dem dating simulator
ein love you colonel sanders empfinger
looking good dating simulator ja ich
weiß auch nicht so genau was uns
erwarten wird dieser dating simulator
ist auf jeden fall entwickelt worden von
kfc dem fast-food-restaurant cathy und
das spiel heißt halt ein love you
colonel sanders und coronel stan das ist
halt der gründer der damals cave sie
halt gegründet hat das haben gründe also
an sich luca allerdings würde ich sagen
wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal of new
game before i get started alassio nehmen
wir wollen uns der nennen drei wochen
später luca
das spiel geht jetzt hier auf jeden fall
und wir sehen schon der ladebildschirm
besteht aus in welchen chicken wings
sind aber schon direkt drin und zwar
steht hier you sleep softly as the
morning sun cars the window für york
modell ist juden warum ich und warum
habe ich ein poster vor dem hütchen in
einem studentenzimmer hängen wir sind
auf jeden fall gerade aufgewacht und
unserem studentenzimmer hier die sonne
weckt uns und da geht's jetzt los als
ich will hier oben rechts einfach mal
auf weiter the world peace von 1
theorien judith staind im moment vor
weise wir könnten wirklich unser leben
lang in diesem moment gerade leben euro
könnte wake up your first day of the
main becker ist eine münchen haben jetzt
die möglichkeit zwischen smack that
caught up and aim oder flott out of the
window und steyn bett vor weil ich würde
sagen wir treffen die typische luca
entscheidungen das heißt wir werden
selbstverständlich die uhr aus dem
fenster school year end gamer und once
in a lifetime opportunity to meet
colonel sanders das heißt ich habe
verpackt
game over all that i hear my topic
antwort ist also eine vorab oder letzte
kennen ich würde sagen lässt drei werte
kennen das heißt wir sehen hier wieder
die wunderschönen chicken wings
eingeblendet dieses ganze video hier ist
bei jay nicht gesponsert von cave sie
also nicht dass sie irgendwie denkt ich
bekomme hier geld dafür dass ich dieses
spiel spielen oder irgendwas das spiel
ist kostenlos und ich hab es bei steam
gesehen und dachte mir einfach hey das
als die lustigen dann mag das normal
aber gut der staat jetzt auf jeden fall
wieder von vorne
das heißt wir schmeißen diesmal nicht
über fenster sondern spektakel allein im
bett des ziel in sinkenden beating the
way to the prestigious university of
cooking school okay das heißt heute ist
unser erster tag an der university of
cooking school
also gehen auf eine koch universität
alles klar wir sind auf jeden fall jetzt
aufgewacht liegen in unserem bett und
denken so ein bisschen darüber nach hey
was werden wir dann kochen wir werden
wieder alles treffen und wir müssen uns
entscheiden zwischen unity experience
liegt also müssen das ganze ein bisschen
ernster nehmen oder julia yourself to
day dream about the future
ich würde sagen ich nehme das ganze sehr
seriös clique dementsprechend die obere
option an
jetzt steht ihr luca wobei ich habe
außer sind ich bin echt super morning
checkliste branche daher kommen zu der
pid die auto reist nach den can stalk
you now also wir haben uns jetzt
fertiggemacht confidential bis das ist
unser kicks den wir uns geschnappt haben
der sich aus wie ein stück scheiße
ehrlich gesagt war okay das ist diese
university of cooking school auf die wir
jetzt kommen werden hier kam sie live
long best friend feuerwehr miriam
absolut lila vorfeld okay die glocke
alexej und dem sv hart heute
actually einmal das antworte ich hätte
sondern sie dazwischen because you re my
little girl ist okay okay alles okay
luca widerwort und sie springt wieder
dazwischen kratz mich ausreden lassen
it's just that this morning and
breakfast von software und einen text an
die grafen von okayama zu gestalten was
sowohl classic miriam arrays bei
masterchef parents okay ihre eltern sind
also schon ziemlich kranke köchl
blablabla wir unterhalten uns jetzt auf
jeden fall so ein bisschen was so von
wegen wir werden das schon schaffen an
dieser schule web.de oder change the
subject to school gossip ich bin für
school gossip summer university mit
magical mystery stories n roller disco
roboter school messages wenn dann
wirklich steht doch nicht im schulflur
so hey es kommt neuer schüler auf die
schule und erst richtig komisch aber mir
ja weiß natürlich wie der neue schüler
heiß und zwar heißt er harland islam ist
holland da wo der herkommt habt bestimmt
keine glatze des powersellers
zinsniveaus geboren formen der typ soll
kräfte haben
das ist ja ein super dating simulator
gebot heißt linken bau des dudens so
hensler data loss of physics down der
applied to him dream i okay also dass
ist scheint ein blick wirklich
irgendwelche kräfte zu haben hier die
laut bahn weitere blabla ist ashley
young zweifel also ich hab mir die meine
beste freundin ist und das ist ashley
die meine größte die wahlen ist um sie
sieht irgendwie aus wie die von team
rocket von pokémon schießt archive but
you can't help but we feel well as i can
get any thing she wants in kinos ist
okay das heißt wir hassen sie irgendwie
aber sind auch neidisch weil sie alles
bekommen was sie haben will helau ashley
sagt lukas
denn hier der chicken jam nimmt mich auf
jeden fall in schutz und verteidigt mich
kennst eschenhahn aliasing also es heißt
wirklich so also es ist also bzw
ein wirklich so zu sein als wenn wir
selbst und voll der schüchterne junge
sind und überhaupt nicht irgendwie uns
selbst führen selbst einsetzen können
und miriam muss uns jetzt verteidigen
vor dieser komischen ashley blabla die
lahmen jetzt auf jeden fall weiter am
werk was sind das für menschen der typ
hier heißt wenn wenn ich weiß auch nicht
wie man auf dem namen kommt die sind auf
jeden fall beide ziemlich arrogant und
sagen so sie seien die geilsten und
sollten hier als professoren arbeiten an
der schule und wer ist das denn es ist
ihr gut wie looking kipp pushing the
dance window directly next to it also
was sind das hier für menschen er sieht
ein bisschen aus wie ein pokemon mit
seinem komischen eckzahn hier ein paar
sekunden später der junge heißt einfach
top da frage ich mich was seine
lieblingsmusik genre ist doof sagt auf
jeden fall ein love you
warum das ist das ziel für dating
simulator ich dachte halt dass ich
irgendwie einer person fragen stellen
oder fragen beantworten muss und blabla
aber anscheinend muss ich jetzt so ein
highschool eben durchleben wir stehen
die ganzen a da ist deutschland wir sind
ja auf jeden fall jetzt im klassenraum
angekommen und es sieht relativ
altmodisch aus also die studie sehen
hardcore unbequem aus die tische das
sieht alles so aus wie vor 20 30 jahren
in der schule
das ist natürlich eine super
mathematische zeichnungen hier an der
tafel in dem text unten steht auf jeden
fall ist einer der job boom an schuberth
ousted as to wonder innen teams besiegt
chip setting ok looking
das ist unser lehrer
ich frag mich wirklich gar nichts mehr
wo ist das ein riesen blick youth cup in
wales hier in our kulinarik los fragt
luca miriam saage maaß besprenkelt herr
den stop dancing auf die uci srl also
university of cooking skills davon ist
der geschäftsführer der hund antwortet
ließ conny professor dort ein make use
and little and love but still demand
respekt ich meine es süß aus aber ich
frage mich immer noch was das hier für
ein spiel ist das ich gerade spiele take
you talk ist professor das ist die beste
wahl ihr toxisches capable of picking up
the doors of fine dining out of nowhere
wind begins to russia around you einfach
so fenster sind geschlossen aber es
kommt irgendein wind rein und nur pinke
blätter fliegen in den klassenraum wird
die den verkehr gebaut der deodorant des
morning displays loomis hot hot hot ok
luca überlegt ein bisschen professor
dogs tags in the text
ok also der hund setzt jetzt regeln an
die die schüler befolgen müssen
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht was
ich dann hier für ein spiel aufgegeben
habe und ich weiß auch nicht warum ich
gerade immer noch spiele ich habe mir
wirklich gedacht als ich bei steam
geschaut habe und gesehen habe hey das
ist ein dating simulator von fcm
vielleicht sitzen wir in einem casey und
essen check points unterhalten uns mit
verschiedenen mädels und blablabla wir
sind in einer klasse mit einem hund als
lehrer und irgendwelchen anderen
komischen typen die uns mobil
das ist spiel aller zeiten ich wollte
auf jeden fall lustig das ganze haus zu
check ich hätte mir allerdings bereit
gerade schon gesagt das ganze ein
bisschen anders vorgestellt wird
allerdings dennoch gefallen da würde ich
mich selber einen daumen hoch von euch
unter dem video freuen können wir gerne
in die kommentare schreiben
ob ich das weiter spielen soll ich meine
das spiel ist kostenlos und es hatte
irgendwie ein paar mb also es wird eh
nicht mehr so lang gehen wenn ihr bock
habt auf den zweiten teil schon gerne in
die kommentare abonniert zudem einen
kanal
wenn ihr noch keiner moment sei das ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
und wenn ich an abonnenten könnte auch
gern auf die glocke klicken dann bekommt
der kamera
[Musik]